I also ask you to present in the state
awards all the military personnel who
distinguished themselves during these hostilities,
based on your daily reports,
they know that in the Russian army there are enough such brave
professional soldiers who are daring for
good, hungry, and
they should all be awarded the
appropriate state
awards.
My congratulations and words  gratitude in
full also applies to the fighters of the
second army corps of the people's
militia of the LPR,
I also know that they acted actively,
competently showing courage and heroism, in the
most direct sense,
the heroism shown during the liberation of
their native land, I congratulate you all
and wish you further success, the
unit that took part in
active combat  actions and
successful victories in the Luhansk
direction
should certainly give up to build up their
combat capabilities the
city is practically not there the city is practically
destroyed
there is no point of issue it is simply broken
there is no this knowledge more like many of
our
mothers  people are walking on the street and crying here
three children are crying, I enter Dalat here,
a certain Dallas was there when, well, how
did the war go, nothing is clear 45
years it was clear, but not everything is incomprehensible
[applause]